exercises for saraza 10
con when you're training from suaza
you're going to be doing this tencon
exercise lot any of the UDA movements we
do will have the same turning idea the
very first step you take is going to be
the most difficult in this my knee is
going to come forward like a regular
Chico step I'm going to drop my knee and
plant it this is going to be my Pivot
knee from here I'm going to turn around
that knee then from this position on my
back leg's just going to come forward
knee to knee so knee to knee and turn
knee to knee and
turn it's important to practice this
over and over you're going to use 10
conon constantly you can do it in
straight lines when you're regularly
practicing shico just turning as you go
absolutely important to practice this
ten con
froma